o ator diz pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo já mais um
vídeo eu mostrar de que mais 1 do que um
jovem de ponto e xz e você já deve estar
a perguntar daqui porque tem um jatinho
fim no teu ao papa
bom pessoal vocês conhecem este tipo de
jogos os pontos x é vocês já sabem que
eu fiz foi chão sempre com a [ __ ] de um
susto e prontinho como já sei que vou
estar com meu mandato ambiente trabalho
já vou ter aqui uma coisa fofinha para
me acalmar e tal é então foi por isso
que o texto ao pai por mais qual é o
jogo de hoje é o toy story ponto é x
apple story é a animação da minha
infância é um dos melhores filmes de
animação toy story um pastor e do egito
story 3 é tipo brutal se vocês ainda não
viram vejam só por falar o mesmo a pena
eo jbic de se programar porque sempre
vocês começam os jogos ponta e xv vai
acontecer alguma coisa aparecer algum
susto assim então eu já estou preparado
e alguma coisa é só fechar o jogo e
olhar aqui como ratinho coffin eu vivia
no longa cueca mas vamos lá então
começar espero que isso não tem a ver os
117 apresenta com a história e ponte x é
só preparem-se para terem a infância
toda estragada ou cair num dia normal
dos brinquedos apenas num dia normal
brincadeira acho que é isso o clube
perdeu a cabeça
acreditam que a brincadeira cabo eo e
entendeu ou não conseguiu ler é um novo
dia para os brinquedos mas alguma coisa
aconteceu mal of the world
[Música]
já não lembro não dela mas ela percebeu
que toda possuída é morta gente segue
o dem precisa brincar orgulho antes
dupla e vamos lá então começar este ano
e no entorno é essa senhora o que é isso
gente rex em tamanho a uma bóia ou ou
fazer coisas que não via há lo
op o lema não apoia e tapira ajuda que
acho que ajuda a dar apoio à amiga
outras várias um tiranossauro rex eo
ajuda as pessoas a amar apoia o que tem
que fazer aqui na frente ao patrão
o uso não consegue escapar da saúde
morto espera já descontam meu canto
d'aqui o último teste de sangue e
quebrou a partir daqui já estragaram
tudo porque é um tiro de cheia de sangue
e chuva
este mês um bicho bicho já entregaram
completamente o personagem não é ea
minha infância minha cueca é o botafogo
que o vôo e elite já não havia escada de
continuar a andar
ambos física jogo de alguma coisa são os
alunos são jovens do filme tv que olha
pra mim tudo na cabeça foi isso tudo na
cabeça
eu penso que estamos num clima não penso
que estou num clima para uma batata
cozinhava alguma coisa se possível uma
batata
só se for uma estadual a este mesmo
estar por aí então este mesmo ratos
controle por favor meu lá ok agora são
um mistério potato é que é uma das
minhas personagens favoritas porque os
segundos todos os braços saem agora está
em tudo não há locais sempre a subir
escadas
meu futuro é este um mel puro é este meu
pode acontecer alguma coisa aqui o bruno
está muito calmo que aquilo que é que o
que é que o avanço é o buzz lightyear o
meu personagem principal está muito alto
mas eu não estou eu não estou agora
ok vem agora ano ainda está já tentaram
eu não assisto meu eu bem que roma não
assustou não conseguiu
ok esse personagem quem não lembra de
sua personagem em questão que está este
é o caso mais forte da história
ana pergunta não tem os bancos grandes e
só isso porque o resto é pequeno lá o
que vai acontecer uma coisa aqui e atira
uma coisa que ele fosse tupi que geram
beco geram picos foge pode mexer meu
disco do músico para o alto ou muito
alto esta porcaria
ok parece que todos os seus amigos estão
mortos
blá blá blá eu não vou ter tanto não vai
dar e não vai ser mais útil tipo não vou
ter mais uso de ti é uma coisa sem
torcida
dark eu disse o menino ao meu lado bom e
ruim de buscar um nome eu pensei 'meu zé
tem uma mente doentia meu é buscar um no
meu pc o game mova e vai acontecer
aquela coisa né
é melhor fechar o jogo é a melhor opção
do jogo vou fechar o jogo contra o auto
itaú e toy story e terminar a tarefa de
contamina terminar a tarefa de ataque e
não foi chato mello xuxa programa chupa
e agora vamos ver quem está fininho ons
ó então é isso pessoal nós vamos ficar
porque com isto a história de ponta e
cissé é isso que vocês querem empurrar a
cueca também em baixa o jogo alguém no
voz pc e vocês vão ver que o zé manel tá
lá atrás aqui vai dar vos ouvido eu
parece mesmo que está dentro de vós
ouvido é muito bizarro jogo y lhe digo
que shahram deixe um comentário deixa o
vosso apoio já sabem light favorito
fique bem e até a próxima
[Música]